hello everyone and welcome back to new
people today we have Hilda harder man
with us you could say Hilda is Europe's
discreet fairy godmother when a crisis
looms in the world she intervene behind
the scenes to solve the crisis with the
EU foreign policy instrument
Hilda knows about traces she comes from
ich in Belgium a region which was
devastated by the first world war
we'll get to ask her if the history of
her hone on town makes her think about
Europe today are you sitting comfortably
then let it begin
[Music]
I am pleased to welcome Hilda
alderman a dedicated European and
Belgium from the region of people we
managed to catch a quitter between two
flights
good morning hi
nice to meet you could you tell me in
few simple words what your job is all
about
I run the Commission's speedboat service
that's a small service that intervenes
fast and flexibly across the globe there
where it's needed for conflict
prevention crisis management peace
building also where we need to support
for instance democratic elections so
those are the type of things that we do
there's many others but I think that
that gives you the first sense of the
type of actions that you undertake some
would say why solving crises abroad when
there are so many crises already in
Europe
what do you answer to that well that the
two are needed if we look at it from a
very selfish point of view a crisis
abroad always entails also certain risks
for the European Union itself so it is
in our interest to contribute to
stabilisation and peace across the world
just like it is in our interest that we
see the development of democracy across
the world so the Commission has
different players different entities
many people look at what is happening in
the EU itself we look at what is
happening outside the EU and the new
outside on issues related to peace to
conflict prevention to democracy has
credibility because of the achievements
that you has been able to bring about in
only over the decades I met you two
weeks ago and you were about to go on
and no style environment training I'm
impressed because I'm seeing you here in
the chair and thinking wow you must have
experienced on some tough moment last
week can you tell us a bit more about it
what can you tell us our service has
people in really dangerous environments
we have people that work for our
civilian crisis management missions in
Iraq for instance we have people in the
Central African Republic which is very a
very difficult environment very much by
the nature of the type of the things we
do people are in risky environments so
as head of the service I want also to be
aware of what that entails but I also
need to be prepared to be able to go and
visit more dangerous places
so Hilda I've got my own hostile
environment question there for you okay
during one minute I would like you to
tell me what the EU did for you citizens
on several international crises okay
can you I'll try ready ready the 2006
and 2009 gas crisis the you helped to
bring gas to homes and factories so that
people were warm and could work the
Ebola crisis
you helped to contain very dangerous
disease trade in Blood Diamond your
helps to make sure that when you buy a
diamond you can be reasonably sure that
it hasn't served to finance a conflict
climate change the EU takes the lead in
international action to protect our
planet for our children and our
grandchildren the mad cow disease you
make sure that you the stake on your
plate is safe and healthy the Colombia
Civil War share the u.s. experience in
peace building and thereby increase
peace and stability globally across the
world Thank You Hilda of all these which
one would you like to highlight maybe
the gas crisis because it's very
concrete and very practical you know
pipelines that transport gas normally
speaking can bring gas only in one
direction with the result that if the
gas is stopped at the start of the flow
that you cannot bring in gas from
another side and this is what happened
in 2006 when gas stopped flowing in the
middle of the winter from the east
entire regions families companies in
eastern and southern Europe were without
gas and what the EU did as a result of
that you invested to equip the gas
pipelines with the double flow so that
cars could flow in two directions
which meant that in
2009 when we were again confronted with
the tap being closed that we could bring
to those regions a gas from northern
Europe from Western Europe and avoid the
problem for the families and the
economic operators all this is really
serious to pick so how do you unwind I
play music and I sing I sing since I was
very small I sang in a village chorus
and I still sing in a bigger chorus
today and I play also music I play the
organ she was playing the organic some
time ago and I heard it was a family
thing to play music because we also got
a picture from your grandfather he's
here I think it's the the first one on
the picture that's correct
my grandfather was the conductor of the
village band and he wanted me very much
to play the clarinet but my mother
didn't like that idea because what to
village one do after the concert they go
home and have a glass so instead she
thought it was better that I played the
piano I did that and then after a while
I started playing also the organ that's
how it came about so she stuck to home
she stuck me home but she also gave me
the time and the opportunity to study
music and it's a big big thing in my
life
[Music]
so Hilda speaking about history in
crisis you know this year we commemorate
the hundredth anniversary of the end of
the First World War and you're coming
from from a city EEP
that is a strong history can you tell us
a bit more about it yes I went to school
in Ypres I grew up in the in division of
Ypres and it was really the front in the
first world war so the city was it was a
big medieval a rich medieval city was
completely destroyed it was also the
place where for the first time in
history they used chemical weapons and
when I grew up and actually even today
so the landscape is full of cemeteries
but also the soil is still full of
unexploded ordnance as children we were
very familiar with seeing the unexploded
obverses etc on the corners of the field
because the farmers would find them they
would take them out of the ground put
them off the corner of the field and the
army would circulate to pick them up
some say that the argument about peace
Europe being a peace project resonates
more with the older generation but that
now it's not enough what would you
answer to that if you come from that
region you don't need to ask what is the
EU for you know it's to fight war it's
to make peace a more philosophical
question to end up with we often hear
that Europe progress only with crisis do
you do you believe in it do you think
it's a fatality that we should progress
only with crisis I do not believe in any
fatalities you know but I think that we
are all human beings and human beings
gets motivated by challenges get
motivated by difficulties so when we
meet an obstacle we do our utmost to
overcome it so from that perspective I
think it's true that crises have helped
the European Union to make progress on
things that really matter
so Hilda thank you very much for your
honest and clear answer thank you
everyone for watching please share
comments we watch it if you wish but we
got the left little game that we're
gonna do with Hilda with the red phone
here it's a bonus video so click here
and if you watch this video you're gonna
learn a bit more about some historical
quotes and international FS if you don't
watch the video thank you for watching
again and see you soon for the next few
people it is
[Music]